bonsoir jean vincent brisset merci de
répondre à nos questions les etats-unis
ont lancé pour la mer de chine
très récemment un vaste plan de
réarmement pour contenir la marine
chinoise dont la puissance plus que
triplé en vingt ans en quoi la mer de
chine est elle si stratégique à la mer
de chine
la première chose c'est quelque chose
que les chinois ont décidé de
s'approprier intégralement
contrairement à toutes les
réglementations internationales et la
mer de chine c'est là où passent 40 % du
trafic mondial de marchandises donc
c'est vraiment extrêmement important
pour l'ensemble de la planète états unis
et chine multiplie les manoeuvres
militaires dans cette zone depuis
plusieurs mois les adversaires se
jaugent se provoque
on cerne la rencontre a en alaska dans
tony blinken avec son homologue chinois
ça n'a rien changé sani la nouvelle ère
biden je pense que l'on est vraiment sur
un nouveau changement de paradigme on a
eu d'abord une époque obama qui a
constaté le problème avec la chine
c'était la première fois qu'un président
américain constaté vraiment le problème
est qu tâche il a parlé de pivot vers le
pacifique
et puis c'est resté au discours ensuite
on a le président trump qui lui est
parti sur un système très différent il y
avait beaucoup un discours cohérent il y
avait des tas de deux tweets n'est pas
de discours cohérent sur la politique
vis-à-vis de la chine
par contre les actions étaient
extrêmement précise et extrêmement
efficace dans le cadre d'un partenariat
bilatéral
parce que le trump ne crois pas du tout
aux grands macha autres grandes
alliances il a récupéré le discours de
trump sur la dureté vis-à-vis de la
chine et par contre byden aidé en train
d'essayer de revenir à des discours
multilatéraliste à des alliances à
décoder une haine contre aux patients
qui seraient pas seulement celle des
états unis
il se retrouve aussi avec des programmes
d'armement qui ont été décidées par
l'administration preuve les est
entérinée par la sienne on va voir ce
que ça donne mais là à l'heure actuelle
les chinois sont dans une phase de test
comme le sont et non en 2015 la chine
assc en tête de 155 bâtiments en lan
compte 360 360 navires de guerre
aujourd'hui soit une soixantaine de plus
qu'à l'us navy est ce qu'on peut
craindre une collision par exemple entre
navire prochainement notamment mer de
chine parce que la situation peut
basculer
alors la situation il ya un risque
effectivement alors explique le nombre
de bâtiments chinois est extrêmement
important le nombre d'équipages
opérationnel au niveau des équipages
américains et est nettement moins à la
faveur de la chine
il y à il y demeure le risque dans la
mesure où il
des bateaux qui vont se croiser semble
de près en mer de chine du sud
il ya des risques de collision des
risques de blacy dans les incidents qui
peuvent dégénérer
parce que les états unis et les marins
américains mais qu'ils assez bien ce
genre d'incident potentiel
j'ai peur que les équipages chinois ont
pas encore le niveau pour maîtriser ce
genre de confrontation et pour les pays
aux alentours
situé dans la zone les philippines alès
la malaisie brunei au sud vietnam aussi
à l'ouest quel danger pour ces avec ses
manoeuvres militaires
quelles conséquences notamment pour
l'industrie de la pêche par exemple les
pays sont se considèrent comme des
victimes de la chine et de
l'appropriation de la mer de chine du
sud par là par la chine de becker donc
c'est le pays aurait tendance à être
assez content de voir apparaître les
américains on voit les philippines par
exemple qui ont craché sur les
américains pendant pas mal de temps et
qui maintenant reviennent un peu véreux
et puis des autres pays de la zone aussi
ont tendance à avoir plus peur de rien
même s'il n'ose pas l'affronter
directement
selon l'amiral américain james stavridis
je cite pékin saic taiwan se défendra et
que les états unis pourra utiliser leurs
capacités militaires pour rendre une
opération militaire contre taïwan très
coûteuse
comment est-ce que vous analysez cette
sortie alors il faut bien se souvenir
que les états unis ont un texte qui a
valeur de loi aux états unis qui les
oblige à défendre la souveraineté de
taïwan
donc ça c'est une première chose et il
semblerait que l'administration byden
d'adam la suite de l'administration
précédente veut bien précisé qu'il
respecterait le royal bangs
certains joueurs sont pour les avis de
même et d'un autre côté il est évident
que le pouvoir chinois qui a une grosse
difficulté à l'heure actuelle on en
parle peu mais c'est in fine à une
opposition interne qui lui poserait pas
mal de problèmes et des rapports avec le
reste du monde à cause de l'épidémie en
particulier qui lui pose pas mal de
problèmes
donc tout ça ça peut conduire
tenter une opération sur taïwan pour
ressouder le pays dans un élan
nationaliste et cette opération contre
eux taiwan serait a priori condamné
quand même par une part des pays du
monde mais j'espère et d'aller à ces
lois parce que les taiwanais qui avait
une arme est relativement faible il ya
quelques années ont maintenant une armée
il sait pas qui peut renforcer ce plan
matériel etc a surtout gagné 1 une force
morale qui ne veut pas merci jean
vincent brisset d'avoir répondu à la
question je rappelle que vous êtes
chercheur associé à l'iris l'institut
des relations internationales
stratégiques et vous êtes spécialiste de
la chine